Trascrizione: Giulia Toffolon
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Quante volte ci siamo chiesti,
in questi mesi,
come ritrovare le emozioni.
Le emozioni ammazzate dalla separazione,
ma anche le emozioni
che appartengono, per esempio,
allo spettacolo dal vivo, o alla danza.
Ecco, il primo periodo dell’anno scorso
l’abbiamo occupato proprio
cercando di rispondere a questo.
Poi ci siamo accorti
che nella ricerca di qualcosa di nuovo
avremmo trovato delle soluzioni
non soltanto per l’oggi,
per la difficoltà dell’emergenza,
ma anche per il futuro.
Perché in fondo, quell’emozione speciale
che appartiene al rapporto
tra un interprete e uno spettatore,
quell’emozione specifica
può anche essere addirittura amplificata
da certi strumenti tecnologici.
E qui ci siamo veramente appassionati:
siamo andati alla ricerca,
un po’ a tentoni naturalmente,
di quelle che potevano
essere le soluzioni,
anche gli spazi possibili
per andare a recuperare
qualche cosa in più.
Bene, per un danzatore
il rapporto col pubblico
è assolutamente fondamentale,
ma il pubblico è sempre
al di là della quarta parete.
Nella possibilità di girare
in realtà virtuale,
nella possibilità di creare
una specie di magico "box"
intorno all’occhio dello spettatore,
noi abbiamo visto una possibilità
straordinaria di prossimità,
che lo spettatore non ha mai,
di cura e attenzione
alla visione del dettaglio,
e anche, perché no, di emozione,
se poi quell’incontro fosse risultato
particolarmente riuscito.
In questo, naturalmente,
abbiamo anche intravisto
una grande sfida tecnologica
per la quale siamo andati
alla ricerca di aiuto.
Quando ci è stata proposta
questa sfida tecnologica,
quando abbiamo cominciato a ragionare
sulla possibilità di introdurre
degli elementi di immersività nella danza
e di fare in modo che il coinvolgimento
di tutti i protagonisti
di questa esperienza -
i danzatori, il coreografo
e anche il pubblico -
potessero in qualche modo
essere innestati in un contesto nuovo,
dove le dinamiche sono cambiate
e dove le distanze
sono diventate una necessità,
ci siamo subito resi conto
di quanto fosse rilevante,
e significativa, questa sfida tecnologica.
E abbiamo fatto
quello che facciamo di solito,
cioè esplorato tra le
opzioni tecnologiche,
indagato su come queste si potessero
sposare con l’esperienza degli utenti,
ma anche quella dei protagonisti del tema,
dell’esperienza che si andava realizzando,
e alla fine, dopo una riflessione
nella quale il dialogo è continuato,
in questo sta anche uno
degli aspetti interessanti del lavoro,
siamo approdati all’idea di realizzare
quella che, tecnicamente,
si chiama la Cinematic VR,
cioè l’idea di una rappresentazione
in realtà immersiva,
quindi l’idea che il pubblico
sia in qualche modo collocato
dentro a una situazione di immersività -
dicevo, la rappresentazione, però,
di una forma visiva autentica,
non di una ricostruzione tridimensionale,
non di un lavoro di elaborazione digitale,
ma esattamente l’autenticità del lavoro
del coreografo, dello scenario di danza
e dunque anche un ruolo da protagonista,
nel caso specifico, dei danzatori.
Ne è uscita un’esperienza colta da tutti,
ancora una volta, come nuova e peculiare.
La possibilità per il pubblico
di indossare questo dispositivo
di immersione completa
anche poi in una versione,
per così dire, più "light", con un tablet,
consente, appunto,
allo spettatore
di vivere una sorta
di totale immersione nella danza.
Quindi di vedere la danzatrice
o il danzatore muoversi nello spazio,
ma anche vedere lo spazio
muoversi intorno alla danza.
Quindi c’è un gioco
nel quale io, spettatore, mi giro
e vedo tutto ciò
che accade intorno a me.
E nel momento in cui questo succede,
succede che anche l’audio,
anche la parte acustica,
che è così importante nell’elemento
emozionale di questa restituzione,
segue lo spazio, mi attornia,
mi insegue propriamente.
Ecco che, a quel punto,
l’esperienza di immersività è importante,
e significativa e totale.
Ma è così, anche,
perché il dialogo non si è fermato
a una risposta tecnologica
di fronte a una sia pur interessante
sollecitazione intellettuale
o sollecitazione, per così dire, estetica,
ma è continuato
nella valutazione degli impatti.
I primi prototipi ci hanno consentito
di capire
che cosa andava, e che cosa
poteva essere migliorato.
Abbiamo lavorato
con le persone, con gli utenti,
con gli stessi protagonisti,
i danzatori, i coreografi.
E abbiamo capito, per esempio,
che l’esperienza immersiva
è insieme avvincente
ma anche, a tratti, perturbante.
perché in qualche modo ti porta, quasi,
ad essere invaso dall’esperienza di danza.
Questo è un elemento
che ci ha sorpresi e incuriositi,
e nuovamente attratti.
Concludo questa riflessione
dicendo che in fondo abbiamo creato,
in questo dialogo molto stimolante,
una sorta di nuova grammatica
della progettazione,
una nuova forma di contribuire alla danza
attraverso la tecnologia;
e che ha, come dicevi tu,
dei tratti e dei passaggi interessanti
sui quali, naturalmente,
lascio a te una conclusione d’insieme.
La cosa più straordinaria
della nostra esperienza
è che non siamo abituati al coreografo
che prende in considerazione
lo spettatore.
Il coreografo, di solito,
ha uno spazio e dei corpi;
e questo è il suo modo di  organizzare
la relazione con lo spettatore.
In questo caso, no:
i nostri coreografi
hanno dovuto immaginare
di far convivere l’interprete
e lo spettatore nello stesso spazio.
Hanno dovuto rivolgersi
ad un immaginario spettatore,
che quando poi, con gli Oculus,
si ritrovano al centro della scena
si sentono davvero parte della performance
e non vi hanno soltanto assistito.